I now want to emphasize an important
point conditional probabilities are just
the same as ordinary probabilities
applied to a different situation they do
not taste or smell or behave any
different than ordinary probabilities
what do I mean by that I mean that they
satisfy the usual probability axioms for
example ordinary probabilities must also
be non-negative is this true for
conditional probabilities of course it
is true because conditional
probabilities are defined as a ratio of
two probabilities probabilities are
non-negative so the ratio will also be
non-negative
of course as long as it is well-defined
and here we need to remember that we
only talk about conditional
probabilities when we condition on an
event that itself has positive
probability how about another axiom what
is the probability of the entire sample
space given the event B let's check it
out by definition the conditional
probability is the probability of the
intersection of the two events involved
divided by the probability of the
conditioning event now what is the
intersection of Omega with B B is a
subset of Omega so when we when we
intersect the two sets were left just
with B itself so the numerator becomes
the probability of B we're defined we
were dividing by the probability of B
and so the answer is equal to one so
indeed the sample space has unit
probability even under the conditional
model now remember that when we
condition on an event B we could still
work with the original sample space
however possible outcomes that do not
belong to B are considered impossible so
we might as well think of B itself as
being our sample space if we proceed
like that and think now of B as being
our new sample space
what is the probability of this new
sample space in the conditional model
let's apply the definition once more
it's the probability of the intersection
of the two events involved B
intersection B divided by the
probability of the conditioning event
what is the numerator the intersection
of B with itself is just B so the
numerator is the probability of B who
are dividing by the probability of B so
the answer is again one finally we need
to check the additivity axiom recall
what the additivity axiom sells if we
have two events two subsets of the
sample space that are disjoint then the
probability of their union is equal to
the sum of their individual
probabilities is this going to be the
case if we now condition on a certain
event what we want to prove is the
following statement if we take two
events that are disjoint they have empty
intersection then the probability of the
union is the sum of their individual
probabilities but who are now the
probabilities that were employing are
the conditional probabilities given the
event B so let us verify whether this
relation this fact is correct or not let
us take this quantity and use the
definition to write it out by definition
this conditional probability is the
probability of the intersection of the
first event of interest the one that
appears on this side of the conditioning
intersection with the event on which we
are conditioning then we divide by the
probability of the conditioning event B
now let's look at this quantity what is
it we are taking the union of a with C
and then intersect it with B this union
consists of these two base pieces when
we intersect with B what is left is
these two pieces here so a union C
intersected with B is the union of two
pieces one piece is a intersection B
this piece here and another piece which
is C intersection B this is the second
piece here so here we basically used a
set theoretic identity and now we divide
by the same numerator as before and now
let us continue here's an interesting
observation the events a and C are
disjoint the piece of a that also
belongs in B therefore is disjoint from
the piece of C that also belongs to B
therefore this set here and that set
here are disjoint since they are
disjoint the probability of their union
has to be equal to the sum of their
individual probabilities so here we are
using the additivity axiom on the
original probabilities to break this
probability up into two pieces and now
we observe that here we have the ratio
of an intersection by the probability of
B this is just the conditional
probability of a given B using the
definition of conditional probabilities
and the second part is the conditional
probability of C given B where again we
are using the definition of conditional
probabilities so we have indeed checked
that this additive 'ti property is true
for the case of conditional
probabilities when we consider two
disjoint events now we could repeat the
same derivation and verify that it is
also true for the case of disjoint Union
or fine of finitely many events or even
for countably many disjoint events so we
do have finite and countable additivity
we're not proving it but the argument is
exactly the same as for the case of two
events so conditional probabilities do
satisfy all of the standard axioms of
probability theory so conditional
probabilities are just like ordinary
probabilities this actually has a very
important implication since conditional
probabilities satisfy all of the
probability axioms any formula or
theorem that we ever derive for ordinary
probabilities will remain true for
conditional probabilities as well